okay welcome everyone to mastering the
middlegame lecture so today I want to
talk about Nigel structures and I'm
going to show a couple of my games are
there any nitro flares are there any for
players will face the neither who play
open Sicilian yeah okay
so I played the night or several times
with blog recently I had a very bad
experience with it I played in the last
round of the US Women's Championship and
I lost and it cost me the title so now
I'm going to show how to get the night
off say forty five so I really like
playing the English attack against the
night off I have a very good score with
it I like the positions a lot does
anyone know what English attack yeah
this should be three you can also start
with f3 and there's a reason why I
played we should be three here so
usually I start with f3 because after
Bishop e3 there is an additional line
you have to know what Knight g4 which is
not something very dangerous but just
more to know the reason I played Bishop
f3 we should be three because I was
trying to confuse my opponent with ammo
border so this game is from 2010
Olympiad this was from the last round
we're playing against the Indian team
and winning would mean that we're going
to tie for third and we did win but
unfortunately we ended up in fifth place
I think but it was still a very
important game of course and very nice
result for our team so I played Bishop
b3 b5 so there are two moves Knight f3
and Knight b3 does anyone know the
difference what is the English attack
setup let's say I played night at night
b3 so was the setup
right so 322 G Castle queenside and
attack so of course if I want to play f3
I cannot put my knight there so what's
the idea behind Knight f3 right Bish's
so if the bishop comes to e6 we can
harass this Bishop so what is week in
blacks position d5 yeah so T v square is
a very weak Square and this distance 1
is what kind of pawn like what's fun
right so for that reason this Bishop is
the bad bishop and this is the strong
bishop so let's say if like that
something like this and of course white
is very happy because there's some more
control of this of this square the
bishop will come to c4 so black ruling
is to hang on to that bishop so Knight
goes to b3 Queen d2 so again mom more
common movies f3 but the reason I played
with Queen d2 because there is also
aligned with f4 and I was avoiding a
line and trying to confuse my opponent
so she played Knight vd7 I've a castle
again keeping up for in mind rook c8 f3
+ h5 so what is significant about this
h5 move yes
right so when I was talking about middle
games uh last time I was mentioning how
to play the middle games well you have
to know you have to understand your
openings so you have to understand how
each position upon affects the game each
move affects the game so how does a h5
affect the position for block right so
what does it mean right so if black
castles if ever black cap oh my god if
like every Castle that means the king is
going to be in more danger so a lot of
times the king is going to stay in the
center until it becomes a lot safer to
castle so what else is going on in this
position so what are the weaknesses what
are the strengths what are the ideas
right night on b3 so we put the other
night on v3 from early on to the setup
but in the long term this night is a
terrible piece doesn't really have any
prospects so always in the game we have
to keep in mind that our night is bad
and our Bishop is bad so so this is this
can be a very short position because we
Castle queenside and this King King is
either going to stay in the center or
castle so there's the possibility of
doing a pawn storm but also in the
long-term reps think about our pieces
and when we're doing exchanges or even
attacking we still need to to make sure
our pieces don't get stuck and we don't
end up in a position where we do a lot
of exchanges our attack doesn't work out
and then we're left with this bishop or
we love with this Knight that cannot do
anything
so king b1 always safe move on so
against this h5 moved there are
different setups there's a specific
setup that I really like so Bishop comes
out of course black has to play in the
Queen side my king is there so h3 so I
think the point that h3 is clear so what
does black do h4 yeah
so now the position has changed and very
important to keep up with the changes so
now the king is in the center so why
should white play
what
Brooke Lemar your mumble right so white
has to play in the center because with
the way that blog committed with this
pawn to h4 and everything it's it's very
scary for black to Castle because I can
just play g3 and open up the position
and I have a direct attack and it's not
clear if blacks counter-attack is going
to be so fast so now we're assuming the
king stays in the center so we have to
switch our ID and play in the center by
427 rook everyone hmm Bishop c4 okay so
so it looked like white the white
developed all the pieces rocks in a
center Knights odd Bishop loud so what
next and it I think this happens a lot
when like we put our pieces on what we
think are the best squares and then we
get a good position and then not sure
what to do next right so we want to see
so we have everything in the center so
we want to see if we can open up the
center because if the center opens up
we're perfectly set up with right all
the rooks are here if I take out this
for pawned this King is going to be very
unhappy so first what we have to look at
is we can just open the center wide open
and see if we can just go straight for
the throat so let's say take 85 so this
is a computer line like I analyzed it
with a computer and computer hangs on
somehow but it looks very scary for
black so I think playing this position
is actually very scary for black because
they have to defend very precisely so
the idea is to keep the center closed
and to not so first of all the
accomplished and the 95 looks very
strong knight in the center but several
disadvantages inviting the knight into
the game you're still stuck with your
backwards pawn and you're opening up the
center a little more so for example if I
play 95 when I sacrifice this pawn I
have an open file on your King but if
you play addy takes e5 you're opening up
your bishop you're still keeping the
center closed and you got
you're bad pawn and now if it's your
turn you can play Bishop before so this
is a very double-edged position it's not
like white is just going to win no white
is a little inaccurate black can create
very good counter play so take 6 o 95
just trying to we don't care about a
pawn the pawn we just want to open up
the position so there are two ways of
playing so take stakes so I don't want
to focus too much on this line it's just
very forced line and like somehow hangs
on
so Bishop g5 so it's just so many pins
but taking this age for pawn just very
tactical mess I mean again like I don't
want to dwell too much on this is like
this is something you calculate so if
you can calculate it out and you
evaluate it correctly then you like this
position is still a playable position so
you can say okay I like the position I
can play it but if your force variation
doesn't work out or you don't like it as
much then we start looking for other
moves but this move has to be calculated
first because we're already all our
pieces are in the center so we want to
see if we can do anything with them okay
so what else cream with them so my first
question we want to ask does black have
any threats yeah so this before move is
a little bit annoying
yeah a three so a three so what does
this mean for black what can black do
double punts actually you want to take
on d3 so b3 I mentioned this before so
your light squares look pretty awful I
don't care about my double punch you
cannot do anything about my double pawns
you cannot put your response anymore
because this Hanks and again your light
squares so I have a very simple plan I
can just put the Bishop bag play here
play here and then ask you where your
pieces are going so we definitely if
you're going to trade your bishop you
should have to trade it with with the
bishop you don't want to trade it with
the night and just give you up so but
there's a way when the pawn goes to e3
what's the move that black really wants
to play so how else can we play before
do these pieces on C file make sense now
before I'll take it why'd you give up
upon okay why not start with rook b8 a
route b8 so now before can be annoying
so actually a5 is a threat now because
this pawn is protected so what should
white do so every move that changes
something a little bit about the
position so now that the pawn is on a
three night before it's main idea for
black a5 before so how do we stop a four
night one
95 I can just take and go a five oh the
Queen is taking sorry 95 if possible
well and so this is the problem when I
insert the movie chose to come with the
displayed actually what I'm not sure
about 95 if I take take are you can take
the pawn so 95 95 is possibility but
again we have to calculate what happens
if I win a pawn so we go to the same
line as we had before basically except
we have a pollinator and I work on b8 so
so the same thing I was talking about
before we have our pieces on the perfect
position black has the same problem he
has all the pieces out but it's not a
doesn't have a very clear plan so night
goes to a 2 so Bishop d8 with the idea
being a 5 so how do we stop a 5
and before so there's now five so queen
bee someone was played tonight five
looks even stronger but something has
something major has changing the
position okay so but I give up the C
file something else in the center in all
those lines that we're looking at how's
the bishop being on d8 different than
being only seven what is more open the
e-file so what does white need to do
right so now we have to look at ways to
open up the center because now if the
center opens up the rook is aiming right
at the king there's no pain there is no
bishop only seven to make it safe for so
what some of you really need to consider
yes right ninety five so compared to the
other position five to five ninety five
and all those lines we were looking at
there was a bishop on it so and the King
was a little safer but now significant
difference in the position so first of
all we stopped a five because the Queen
is open and now we want to see how our
opponent is going to react to this move
so first we have to have such a terrible
memory of what happening like it so now
we have to calculate lines because when
we play a move like ninety five we can
just play it and hope it works out so
let's say what happens if Knight takes
so we have to take a lot of context
right so Bishop c4 so of course if
Quincy Quincy for just just look for
like blacks positions just falling apart
everything's hanging Knights hanging
this pawn is hanging this pawn is
hanging so if if Queen d2 so we have
options so your Bishop d2 92 rook to
Bishop episode who's gonna be taking on
c4 so units and once these six foals if
I was going to fall this this point is
not going to live for very long so now I
just position it's falling apart so now
wait an endgame but it doesn't matter
because not every attack needs to end up
with a checkmate we can just win in the
endgame and this is what I was talking
about when I said let's take into
account the long-term weaknesses and
which pieces we want to exchange which
pieces we want to keep because this d6
pawn which was not a target before all
of a sudden endgame is very weak as well
as it's a 6-1 so in the game she took on
d3 queen takes and castle so now a lot
of things have changed so what's going
on in the position now
all expert bishops something else
significant has happened
okay so Black has canceled that's true
another major exchange has happened
right so you so you could the six is
still a weakness but we could shut off
the file so we're not aiming at it
anymore
so this is a big deal in the position
because we don't have this I mean we
still have the target but it's harder to
attack so what else what is black trying
to do right so a5 a4 before so black
actually has a very strong attack one
can we can is our attack as powerful as
white attack that's the big question
no okay
there's not for census it's if you could
get an ID on c6 that'd be great
well 95 I would not suggest but the
thing is the more things we're saying
like the more things we notice about the
position and then all of a sudden clicks
and then you find a move and that's what
we need to do during the game looking at
the position you like you you kind of
have pieces together but more things you
say it about the position to yourself
the more things you notice and then you
understand what's important about the
position because this position is
significant different significance
different than what we're looking at
five moves ago there are more pieces
there other some things were irrelevant
other things weren't as relevant so it's
a new position so what was the week yeah
this week so how can we attack these six
right so again when you ask when you
really look at the position deeply and
you ask yourself these questions then
they become you notice them because if
you look at the position the six like it
looks weak but you say okay there's no
way to attack it but then what do you
think about the position deeply it's
more easier find solutions so Bishop d2
does two things stops a5 so if you let
your opponent play a five okay let's say
I make random move all sudden this looks
so scary for be like a four with a
temple before this B file opens up and
now we have to worry about not getting
checkmated so Bishop d2 so my opponent
went Queen a7 still trying to go a5 so
we can actually stop fi by just putting
piece there but we have a table move
so take only five night takes and IFC a
little less attention we should be for
yeah another thing I have to say about
moving the bishop we tied down this
night because the night cannot move this
one is hanging so we should so be sure
before was a good move which of course I
didn't play so here so actually this is
a fourth line and this has a lot to do
this is something I've been working on a
lot and of course this game was six
years ago so I still had a problem with
it if like if I would play a sharp line
I was very attached to trying to attack
and trying to somehow create a checkmate
so now I'm trying I'm doing the same
thing that I'm telling you is to
summarize the position and look at a
bigger picture and always keep up with
the changes in the position so here it's
harder to attack because we exchanged a
lot of pieces it's harder to open up
files but when there was a knight on f6
we had this idea of g4 g5 like temple
moves or just pushing everything forward
and here it's not so easy to do that and
our opponent has this one but so if you
look if so this is a first line so we
have to calculate down this line so if
we exchange everything and we reach this
position and one of the important things
of EV out of calculation is evaluation
so ROC t8 is impossible it's not the
date because I can simply take so bishop
has to move
I'm here so how to evaluate this
position right let's rotate to let's
evaluate so we calculate so we
calculated this force line so we have to
decide we want to play this line or not
so so we need to evaluate the position
to decide so yeah so so this here so
this D 7th pawn is a major string for
white because black has to dedicates the
piece or even two pieces to stopping it
so okay my pieces are tied down to
defending it but what black doesn't
really have any good counter place so I
can simply improve my position I can put
my Queen here and yeah and then I can
bring my knight around my knight goes to
g5 and it's it's hard for blog to find
moves let's say you cannot play a move
like this because I'm in trouble okay I
can play c3 first to be more accurate no
you're right because we should before
I'm going to lose upon so yeah I can put
a pawn on c3 so black doesn't really
have any active counter play so that
gives me time to do whatever I want when
your opponent has counter play your
opponent has active ideas then you have
to respond to them but when your
opponent is just tied down doesn't have
any moves then gives you time to improve
your position so I'm not sure why the I
didn't go down this line again like I
said I was like very attached to trying
to checkmate my opponent but of course
if we evaluate the position we see that
we see that line that position which is
very good for white or white so I played
Bishop c3 so takes actually I thought my
bishop on c3 is very strong and now that
the pawn that the pawn is gone
our Knight is free so at some point or
not can finally join the game so 94-95
so nine to six
so here I thought if Sochi after a long
thing she decided to play Bishop f6 and
sacrifice exchange here during the game
I thought if simply take take my bishop
is extremely strong and still aiming at
the King it's very hard to hang on to
this pawn if you play something like
this this King is extremely lonely I can
pick up this pawn and long term I
thought I just have a very very strong
guitar
well hopes of a very strong attack but I
mean vise position is still better of
course my bishop is better than this and
you have a weakness Castle can use the G
file but of course Bishop before was
objectively still the best move so so
Bishop f6 the Queen f2
now it's funny because I'm looking at
this game and like I'm thinking about
what I was thinking about I realize like
I still thinking about going after this
king so my opponent my opponents is
desperately trying to find counterplay
so this game might not for a while and
quite eventually won so what's an
important game for a team okay so so the
game went on for 20 more moves I don't
want to show that so let's move on to
okay so again playing so this is two
years ago and Reykjavik open playing the
same line 6h Wow - this position can
come from different borders black can
play h5 sooner or one move later
so not going to focus too much on the
opening just to reach the same position
so I really like this setup so I always
play it I always played I always play
the same things so a three
actually God got the same exact position
but during the game I was so this was
two years ago daughter game was six
years ago so I wasn't sure if it's the
same position or not okay I have a very
bad memory I can remember my games so I
was spending some time and my point was
to and actually I'm not sure why would
he if you saw that game why he would
repeat it because White has got a better
position so my opponent went castle so I
got the same position so I this time I
didn't find the best move which is so
instead of improving I'm going in
opposite direction
so in my first game I found the best
move so this time I played differently
so I decided that I need to check made
my opponents I went to three so you know
very one-dimensional kind of thinking
the King is there I need to go to three
I need to checkmate so H takes rook g1
another FF II so the reason I play that
five is to make this bishop very bad I
had this big dreams of my knight landing
only four and taking this pawn and just
playing Bishop h6 and I'm very
straightforward kind of thinking so I
mean White's next move is pretty obvious
route you wanna take the pawn and then
double and checkmate so actually I want
a really nice attacking game but then my
coach was mad at me anyways because I
played you what's White's most dangerous
piece when you're trying to attack the
Queen so what has to do something about
this Queen
not sure what before does I'm going to
go away for so how can blog try to
exchange Queens Yeah right Quincy seven
Quincy four so another idea behind 27
Quincy four is that if I try if I don't
exchange Queens now you can simply put a
bishop on edge for the Queen defended
which can be quite annoying so something
so here and now end up in this end game
which you know playable and game so we
can say so you can have a preference if
you like wider block of course it's just
playable for both sides so my opponent
van rook c8 mister page four so there's
no Queenie for because rook c4 so same
idea but he's not threatening to
exchange Queens
so the bishop has moved so which square
is available right so 95 it so Queenie
for because there is no more quincy for
well it's blocked to move so black move
to Bishop we had the bishops under
attack so so now the night is hanging
the night has to move so actually this
position is already very dangerous for
black because my night is my night is
grade simple to read again route III
book g1 just going after the King's Own
not nothing sophisticated in this game
so night b8 trying to exchange pieces
takes so how to take with the queen or
the rook
right so again you want to play this
Quincy form so my opponent that my
opponent is reacted very poorly so it
took with the Queen and soon the game
was over so broadcasts who gets to take
actually also for another reason
so if Bishop g5 the King just runs away
and turns out if I try to do something
the Kings just stays in only seven and
it's very hard to get through the King
and like the c2 point is weak
Quincy for ideas before ideas so I can I
can just do whatever I want I have to be
a little cautious so black has enough
counter play to defend here so my
opponent played a very careless slim run
my so it took with the Queen rook g3
proxy for where does the Queen go yep so
here blacks position is already falling
apart engage eight
mineral G 1 right on top G 1 so now
we're actually threatening to take so
you create
one fish
so while it should be five right because
this Bishop on f6 is the main defender
the bishop is gone because everything
we're doing is on the dark squares once
this bishop is gone this position is
just not going to hold up so Bishop g5
Queen here after your e2 I put it pin
after yep so I'm trying to do now
checkmating on edge file so g6 desperate
and tons I think next move resign you
got the pawn
next upon I think a lot of things you
know so takes
okay so let's calculate the other one
I'll tell you one yeah too much my pawns
and if the Queen takes Bishop takes
Bishop to Queen takes I think I found
yeah so that's what I play queen h5 here
and changing directions because if I
take on f6 Queen takes and defense so
this side take on g6 everything falls
apart
actually I think I have another one here
so take Queen takes I think I can just
take because if you take my queen I have
meat
yeah but in this position I mean there's
just so many ways you just have to pick
one and make sure it works actually its
way it happens a lot when you have a
winning position you think everything
wins and then you pick the worst one
okay so next one because we have time
this one was played 2013 so before the
one that I just shot say 45 so f3 is I
mentioned to stop the 94 move
so f4 so again not playing my same can
be one so ended up on the same position
and then my opponent castles so now this
castle is much different than the castle
in the other position so what's going on
here so g4 is one idea but let's compare
this position to the other one so how is
this position castle to compare to the
other one
that's canceled yeah so blacks counter
play is not coming as fast what else so
if Y is just starts pushing like a5g4 g5
is it more dangerous or less dangerous
compared to the other position so you
think White's attack just like shoving
my pawns is less dangerous in this
position than in the other one so I can
open the other position so this position
compared to this well compared to this
position so in which position is on move
thank you for g5 scarier
you just told me the other one why
pushing your passwords because it won't
pieces in the way do it ah
so before you said it's hard to type got
there more pieces when I telling me it's
easier because there are more pieces
right because if I go F 5 if I can just
go a 5 g 4 g56 everything is with a
tempo and black has to react to it and
in this in the other position this one
this one in this position if I go G for
g5 f 5 so it's 3 moves and none of them
are tempo moves so that gives my
opponent time to go like a5 a4 and
everything my opponents doing with a
temple which so I got yelled at for 54
ok alright so what what's the best way
or how do you want to start this attack
so g4
so you want to play g4 first or what do
we want to throw in a five I mean okay
we can't go after the h4 pawn but like
even if you go and you take the h4 pond
and I'm not sure so after i-5 is not
going to take Bishop you can go to c4 I
mean if my up with my opponent take to
go I'll be so happy if I love that but
but like do we want to go g4 g5 do we
want to play a 5/4 that's black want to
do anything so we have to consider these
things right so I played that 5 to 4
similar reasoning because if I go to 4th
so if I go g4 first first of all we have
to calculate before but that aside
something like this all of a sudden if
you go here here then where is it
exactly is your attack so of course the
knight can go to d4 than before still a
complicated position still I would
prefer white but makes our attack a
little bit tougher so of course every
move we have to calculate what's going
to happen after before but f5 so I
played this move and I really like this
move because G 4 and now we have a
threat we'll just want to push g5 f6 and
just push everything back so my opponent
took the rook g1 before
yeah he write that the time is very
important so I don't care so much about
pons I just don't want like to get
counterplay because once I take one g3
it's very hard to for black to find
defense because g7 pawn is a major
weakness and my pieces are just getting
in so fast so by the time it takes it's
time to take all the spawns I have a
very strong attack so 95 so actually I
was very surprised because I spent so
much time calculating here because this
is a big decision to play 9500 my
opponent played so fast I mean I was
really surprised how can you play so
fast in such a dangerous position
so he took um so you can't take like
this too and here I believe I was
thinking about this Bishop h6 move and
then doing this I'm just making sure the
King doesn't escape because I really
need my dark square Bishop to attack so
I didn't want to just give it up but I
also think that rook g3 is very
dangerous and then double the ropes and
Queen h6 is a threat and the King let's
say you can have a cocaine gate seven I
always have f6 on Queen h6 is a move
strong move so very hard to find
accurate defense for block so my
opponent actually took here and here so
how to capture back so everyone let's
take with the pawn right so what so
again a lot of things change in the
position so why is taking with a pawn
good besides the fact that we're
stopping quincy for not sure so if you
ever play d4 i'm going to play e4 and
then this bishops is going to be bad so
first we get the C file second when we
take on g3
and also our queen is on this diagonal
in case i'm going to trade bishops and
my queen can drop to h6
and also in some cases my knight can
jump here here and I get the C files if
my attack doesn't work out so I have
disadvantages and also this p4 pawn is
hanging so my opponent played Bishop h4
take the pawn so he made another bad
move but this makes sense of course I
mean it's a bad move because I have a
reputation but the way his flying makes
sense because if he loses this g3 pawn
then this row tag is very strong but if
we can hang on to this pawn is shutting
down the whole G file and if we somehow
end up in an endgame all of a sudden
this g3 point is going to become very
dangerous so what to do now if I want to
Queen f6 again a lot of options for what
but Queen g4 is on white is already
almost with egg white is winning because
queen g4 just paralyzes block Queen
cannot move Bishop cannot move Knight
really doesn't have any squares cannot
go to f6 cannot go to b6 I'm going to
take you so black is just running out of
options so what is why it's very simple
idea Bishop Asians are the Queen f6
which also looks money
well uh black most likely is going to
put a queen on f6 so okay actually he
did put a queen on f6 but imagine I'm
just passing the move to white what
would you like to do that's six point of
627
no because how long she was asking
questions so if you take on g3 I'm going
to take everything and put a pawn on f6
rook F seven and just like defined my
position so our opponent is completely
paralyzed that means we have time to
improve something what was our worst
piece so where does our Knight really
want to be right so wide was simply to
transfer the knight here and then I can
either take on g3 maybe I can push f6 if
I put my knight only four I can't even
play Bishop h6 even cannot put a piece
on f6 so black is just completely tied
down so black doesn't have any active
moves does black doesn't have counter
play which gives us the option to play
very active so my opponent made a very
bad move zone so what should white do
now I did - so now you're inviting 94
with the temple so Queen f6 but I mean
in this position it's so hard to suggest
the move so it's like when your opponent
is in a bad position it's so easy to
fall apart offers if you're in a bad
position so easy for you to fall apart -
of course so 90 - so Knight f3 is simply
just trapped and okay the game continued
for a few moves but actually I think you
resigned here yeah so different
positions so if we compare like the
castle in this position castle in the
other position how position changes
keeping up with the changes of the
position so it's very important to
constantly you're summarizing the
position asking yourself what's change
is significant and you're not really
stuck on one idea like that game that I
showed you and you know I admit it it
happens it still happens to me like when
I see an idea and I really like it it's
very hard to let go but it's very
important you make yourself to look for
this kind of you know you ask yourself
these questions you know what change in
the position has you're not just playing
the same idea you had 10 moves ago
that's no longer relevant all right so
this is it for today so thank you for
coming